let me start you with the poll question
here Brian you ready for this yeah I am
dan Pauly get Brian the poll question if
you had to give your list of the
greatest players of NBA history of all
time who would be higher up towards the
top of your list Larry Bird or LeBron
James LeBron yeah LeBron could have
longevity you can't you can't argue I
mean if you want to make this argument
LeBron's best three seasons Larry Bird's
best receiving great argument longevity
does count towards this I mean like
LeBron crushes Jordan's record and he's
like not slowing down anytime soon
something has to be said for longevity I
agree I'm right there with you and if
you do take the best three seasons from
Byrd and LeBron then it's a push but I
have to factor in that LeBron is played
longer played more minutes
is going to be up there and assists in
steals and points on the all-time list
there and Larry had a great run but the
bad back cut that short yeah I am Lenny
what's impressive about LeBron and you
know John Barry brought to my attention
yesterday this guy has been the most
hype player to ever come out of high
school and he has crushed destroyed and
stomped out those expectations I think
when did everyone live anyone live up to
the height and never do they actually
destroy the expectation so I'm going to
give him a lot me like today's day and
age squeaky clean image you know
obviously he's kind of like a polarizing
figure people want to compare him to
Jordan which i think is like the utmost
compliment but man hey all the hype all
the surrounding the 100 million dollar
contract before he even played a game
and he is I just stomped out those
expectations destroyed those but Brian
if we didn't have Jordan to compare him
to with LeBron be more liked embraceable
because he he's not he's not beloved
I think he's respected not beloved do
you think have to do that Miami thing
though I think the decisions up with it
with the Bulls and you know like the
jumps and downs whatever like because
the scenario is but him leaving in Miami
not one not two not three I'm taking my
talents of south because don't doesn't
all that kind of play into this yes
yeah the delay just get the Jordan thing
I like to take away let's say okay
Jordan was
you know Jordan with three entry in the
vitals and he has three championships
like let's just take that out of it
I do think that people would gravitate
towards Avanti he's the greatest ever
still I think the problem is chasing the
rings coming back to Cleveland like that
whole thing I like I kind of threw
people off but I will say that him
winning a championship sort of like the
lid him a little bit and I'll tell you
what Dan if he can somehow pull this one
off then I think there's a conversation
to be had I don't think there's a
conversation to be had right now but I
think there will be a legitimate
conversation if he could somehow beat
this goal as they were team I do too I
I'm right there with you lock step and I
know that people cringe when they hear
that that you want to compare the two or
at least look at their resumes but I
think we're going to do that if that
somehow happens let me ask you about the
Celtics future because they over
achieved that feels like they're a year
or two ahead of schedule I don't think
the East is great but if you're trying
to game plan now of trying to win a
championship what do you do with this
roster as you move forward having the
number one overall pick
knowing Cleveland is still going to be
good next year and probably the year
after that yes I think they're at the
point now where the next move is I going
to be as clear as day Dan it's not going
to be like them trying to get a pick
then you know giving a late take for
Isaiah Thomas and see how it's going to
work out they're not there past that
stage now they're at the point now where
every move that they make it's going to
be a monumental Hall of Fame and type of
player that they're going after which is
a good place to be in you don't have a
guess anymore you don't have to guess
like who the next guy is going to be
like if there's a chance to get an
Anthony Davis you go out there and you
get Anthony Davis that's just it's a
no-brainer in that situation I don't
even think to be honest with you I think
like the Paul George
Jimmy Butler conversations are almost
going to die down now because this pick
ends up being the number one pick and
next year's drafting you have young
Jalen Brown I think that next move is a
monumental move which for them maybe you
get it maybe you don't you know maybe
you sign Gordon Hayward maybe you don't
but they're going to obviously go for
those things but you can't Bank on
Gordon Hayward saying no to Utah and
passing up on 40
in dollars but it doesn't mean you don't
try to go ahead and do it it doesn't
mean you don't call me Orleans and say
can we make this tree to get you know
like this guy who can really take your
team to another level and you try the
team say no then you continue to execute
but I don't think that they make any
rash decisions you know try to make
lateral move if now is the time to make
a move that is going to solidify you as
a champion
if Isiah Thomas was six three putting up
these numbers would we be having this
discussion that he somehow expendable
and they're a better team without it if
he was sixth read and we wouldn't got
him from Phoenix like the idea that he's
a five nine and you can never win with a
guy like this and all and he only makes
you know 6.2 million dollars next year
if he was 63 we the conversation would
be like man we need an Isiah Thomas and
herky that would be the conversation you
wouldn't pick them up or like that 27th
pick in the draft
so like when the Celtics are rebuilding
Phoenix is not all of a sudden that's
going to give up an Isaiah Thomas you
take the risk on a guy because he is 5 9
and that's how the Celtics got him the
rest of the world didn't see the game
changing the way that maybe Danny did or
Vantage's happen to like them and in the
league happen to go small at the exact
same time and the explosion of you know
the spread for and high pick-and-roll
and Isiah Thomas all comes to fruition
now but it's like 63 this conversation
isn't we're having a conversation like
how much better is even Russell
Westbrook or James Harden if he's 6 for
3 any chance the Celtics tinkling cymbal
is a chance if multiple folks comes in
and the medical is not good on him Danny
in the path I'm no Danny for a long time
now if the medical is not good on a guy
he can prove 100% trust his doctors in
the evaluation process if the medical
was not good on him they'll pass on him
I don't know why you know the medical
would not be good on him he missed a few
games here I never had any major crazy
injuries or you know the meniscus taken
out or an ACL or nothing like that so
why the medical would be bad on him I
don't know but they are going to
evaluate him and then it could become
like an issue if the doctors say no then
it's like man we don't even waiting to
bring in Alonzo walling and this is his
scenario what do we do and it's like you
have to bet and find out as much as you
can about
so that's a scenario I doubt it's going
to happen but that's it we're talking to
Brian Scalabrine who works for Comcast
SportsNet New England the Cavaliers will
win the title if if klay Thompson
continues to play the way he's been
playing I mean he has to break out of
this one to do go and check this out
obviously we know the lawyers have
steamrolled the Western Conference right
we all can identify that Klay Thompson's
net rating during the playoffs - 11
that's that's like like it's almost like
bothersome to understand like how with
all these great players out there how
have you and your team been this bad
like you're such a good player you are a
clutch Reuter
I think coach clay I think I've never
thought in a million years he would even
go into a slump and he has been in the
slump this whole playoffs so I think
that he needs to play average too you
know like now above average not great
not game six of OKC last year he needs
to play that way and then if Kevin Love
continues to play at this level that's
how the cats went to a bad Thompson and
a phenomenal love would be Cavs win but
I just I don't know I just don't see
that happening this storyline emerged
here after Kyrie had his big night that
Kyrie Steph Curry who would you take and
I'm thinking but where did how did this
happen but all of a sudden Kyrie has
this break big game I love him he hit I
think he's talented his handles as good
as Curry's maybe better but he he's not
Steph Curry to me I mean you were you
coached Steph Curry maybe your liest but
who would you take is this an argument
Kyrie Irving Steph Curry
um it's I guess looks like if you want I
see it let's go with the 30,000 foot
view I would say no it's a Steph Curry
conversation but start dissecting the
game like for isolation Tyrese better in
isolation and pick-and-roll Steph
Curry's better off the ball like you
know catching shoot situations Steph
Curry's better defensively Kyrie is
better so and that's then that's
defensively when he's engaged not like
there was a absolute embarrassment to
watch the Cavs play because during that
time but I love wimpy birthday they
can't put the switch I'm like well they
surely flip the switch off on G
and so why can't they put their back on
to defend so you know there's some
there's some comparison it's just when
you see a guy and we always overreacted
this is why we put Kobe Bryant so great
it's like when you see a guy who
isolates a guy one-on-one and makes
tough shots and does amazing things not
you know the Spurs moving the ball
around and getting right open shots and
that equaling them winning when this
guys go one-on-one against guys like
every Bradley Terry was here Marcus
smart they do that knee destroy them
like that it's like it's overinflated
those two points are overinflated it's
still two points and I think he's one of
the best isolation players in the league
or is the weakness to his game but the
optimal shooting of Steph Curry in
today's day and age with the team that
they have in dream on running point
guard it's a real problem it's going to
be a good matchup though I think Steph
Curry outplayed them this final I don't
think it's going to be like we saw last
year Ryan always good to talk to you
thank you
all right Dan that's Brian Scalabrine
the white Mamba the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience